pop
[Musique]
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
veulent après midi bonjour voici donc
pour la première fois votre nouvelle
émission aujourd'hui madame maurice
cazeneuve directeur de la deuxième
chaîne de télévision on a confié la
direction la responsabilité armand
jammot et cette émission ce programme
vous sera proposé cinq fois par semaine
c'est à dire les mardis comme
aujourd'hui les mercredis les jeudis et
vendredis et les samedis
pourquoi une émission à une heure
jusqu'à présent inhabituelle à la
télévision est bien pour apporter un
petit peu de détente et aussi parfois
quelques sujets de réflexion à tous ceux
qui d'entre vous qui sont obligés d'être
à leur domicile dans l'après midi
je pense plus particulièrement aux
personnes âgées à tous ceux d'entre vous
qui travaillent le matin ou le soir
et puis aussi à ceux malheureusement
d'entre vous qui sont malades ou
convalescents et à qui je souhaite très
sincèrement une très prompte guérison
est très prompt rétablissement et puis
aussi il ne faut pas oublier toutes
celles d'entre vous qui se consacre aux
soins de leurs foyers au soin de leurs
enfants et qui sont évidemment chez elle
après midi une fois que votre mari est
parti au travail et que vos enfants sont
à l'école look quand ils sont beaucoup
plus petits qu'ils sont avec eux va être
cette émission que vous réserve tel est
bien c'est un petit peu ce que vous en
ferez vous même entendons nous bien le
souci principal d'un mangiamo et son
équipe et est de faire cette émission
pour vous ce qui va sans dire mais aussi
de la faire avec et ainsi chaque jour
comme aujourd'hui vous le verrez dans un
instant ils accueilleront sur ce plateau
3 téléspectatrice que nous aurons
choisis parmi toutes celles d'entre nous
qui nous feront un plaisir de nous
écrire soi d'une carte postale soit une
petite lettre pour nous faire part de
leurs problèmes de leurs préoccupations
et pour nous dire ce qu'elles ont trouvé
d'intéressant ou non dans cette émission
et moins encore avant de vous laisser
regarder cette émission dont on parle
beaucoup depuis quelques jours et vous
demander après tout ce qu'elle va être
bien il fallait absolument que nous
ayons l'après-midi sourire féminin pour
égayer cette émission ce sourire c'est
celui des vignes georges c'est une jeune
femme que vous découvrez en ce moment
sur votre écran hélas à 28 ans elle est
jeune jolie intelligente charmante elle
n'est pas mariée je le précise
et elle va vous présenter tout de suite
le sommaire de cette première émission
vient la grande dame du cinéma français
madame françoise rosay a bien voulu
accepter d'être notre première invitée à
aujourd'hui madame monsieur marcel
antonio secrétaire d'état au tourisme
répondre à cette question comment les
français va style leurs vacances pour la
première d'aujourd'hui madame marcel
amont chantera quelle belle journée
marcel amont
monsieur et madame privat marié depuis
24 heures porteront peut-être chance à
aujourd'hui madame et nous souhaitons qu
aujourd'hui madame en tout cas leur
porte chance également
enfin à 15 heures votre feuilleton ma
sorcière bien aimée et peut-être
aurons-nous le temps également de vous
présenter un nouveau jeu et bien voici
monsieur madame privat les jeunes mariés
deux joueurs du mahram qu'evelyne vous a
présenté à l'instant dans son sommaire
nous les avons choisi pour inaugurer
aujourd'hui madame
il doit être aussi des missions du
couple puisqu'ils commencent leur vie à
deux en même temps que prend naissance
cette nouvelle émission et les espérons
ainsi sommes un petit peu superstitieux
nous porter chance mutuellement il va
madame prix va s'appeler nadine de ma
guerre jusqu'à vendredi soir
elle a 21 ans elle était peut-être
comptable quant à son mari il s'appelle
gérard privat il a 22 ans il est
charpentier de marine
vous êtes rencontrés en vacances à l'île
d'oléron
gérard privat est originaire de
l'hérault oui et vous êtes rencontrés
sur la plage
ensuite il est parti faire son service
militaire deux ans sans permission
m'avez-vous des deux ans intermission
vous l'avez attendu très gentiment très
patiemment vous venez de vous marier et
vous êtes marié exactement samedi 16 mai
à 15 heures à notre dame de la croix de
ménilmontant je dois dire que votre mari
gérard voudrait devenir menuisier
ébéniste et bien michel hallé les
problèmes
monsieur madame privat est ce que vous
êtes pense que c'est une question qu'on
peut vous poser je me souviens de mon
propre mariage est ce que vous êtes bien
loger est ce que vous avez réussi à
trouver un appartement sont conformes à
paris améliorez votre avis combien de
pièces de pièces une petite cuisine pour
l'instant deux pièces une petite cuisine
locale et dans quels quartiers dans le
xxème vermine longtemps et vous espérez
l'améliorer c'est à dire le décor est il
amené le corps et mettre le confort et
votre mari est charpentier de marine
ça semble une tâche assez facile pour
lui donc d'autre part monsieur prix va
vous voulez devenir ébéniste menuisier
oui quelle différence y at-il entre eux
parce qu'il est difficile de passer du
métier de charpentier de marine celui
d'ébéniste si vous passiez à nouveau ses
ap oui oui et en plus le travail de sur
les bateaux n'est pas du tout pareil que
sur les moeurs mais on peut faire des
meubles de marine nous non ça serait ça
se faire genre nouveau en tout cas il va
vous falloir passer donc à nouveau c'est
après c'est ça oui c'est à dire faire de
reprendre des études tout en continuant
à travailler
oui et vous allez pouvoir y parvenir je
pense votre femme travail madame privat
oui qu'est-ce que vous faites comme aide
comptable vous voulez combien d'enfants
crois que monsieur le bret qui vous a
suivis accompagnés que vous avez un
petit un petit peu servi de témoins en
tout cas elle nous représentait leur
présenter aujourd'hui à filmer pour nous
votre appartement seul à pouvoir vous le
présenter maintenant
voilà attention l'instant le petit film
sur l'appartement commenté par michel
brethes
c'est un petit appartement de deux
pièces avec une petite cuisine qui se
trouve à paris
le voici nous sommes dans la petite
cuisine justement elle est toute petite
et gérard et nadine veulent en faire une
salle d'eau qui paie sans doute d'un bac
à douche clients voici encore la cuisine
vous voyez qu'ils sont entassés toute la
vaisselle et ustensiles qui ne savent
pas orange est pour le moment voici
l'entrée gérard la créance et parents de
une pièce qui existait au moyen d'une
cloison an lapd et que nadine a tapissé
d'un papier adhésif qui est très gaie et
sur lequel se détachent les portes et
les moulures qui l'ont peinte en rouge
vif
voici ce qui sera la cuisine avec le
début
l'étagère à épices qui sera complété par
toute une série d'éléments de style
western que gérard veut faire il a déjà
posé les tubes qui éclaireront les plans
de travail quand la cuisine sera
installé puisqu'il a fait lui-même
l'installation électrique
nous sommes dans la salle de séjour ici
au mur les coquillages qui l'a ramassée
sur la plage d'oléron et qu'il
complètera par des filets de pêcheurs
qu'ils espèrent trouver aux puces et les
coquillages des petits serpents de plage
les étoiles de mer tout ce qu'on peut
ramasser sur la plage d'oléron
un petit secrétaire bar qui sera
remplacé par un meuble long et badens
gérard a déjà fait les plans et qui
contiendra les disques l'électrophone le
bar et qui remplacera ce petit meuble
qui est tout petit autour des fenêtres
il y aura probablement des étagères
bibliothèque et voilà une petite girafe
est très très vite
tout ça est très jolie elle rompt peut
révéler un petit peu que le budget le
mariage et l'appartement ont
pratiquement et plonger votre budget et
vous n'avez pas pu partir en voyage de
noces argy une très bonne nouvelle à
vous annoncer monsieur madame privat la
ville de biarritz et le comité de
coordination du pays basque cher à
marcel habran derrière nous offre huit
jours de vacances dans ces très très
joli pays
voilà et bonne chance le signal sept
d'entre vous qui nous regarde en ce
moment qui nous prêtent attention tu
nous reverrons très prochainement dans
les émissions suivantes monsieur madame
privat puisqu'ils nous ont donné leur
accord pour faire avec nous pour
réaliser avec nous une sorte d' enquête
vivante sur les problèmes qui peuvent se
poser un jeune ménage et d'un problème
que beaucoup d'entre vous connaissent ou
inconnues et grâce à eux nous essaierons
pouvoir qu'elles sont à travers eux les
problèmes de jeunes ménages en 1960
décès puis six autres le problème est
bien je pense que vous les avez trouvé
suffisamment sympathique pour bien
vouloir avec nous leur porter aide et
assistance
[Musique]
3 téléspectatrices donc dans ce studio
madame je vais vous demander de vous
nommer de nuit oui voilà marié lise
berthaud mhamedi toutes les trois vous
êtes mère de famille non juste un vrai
sauf excepté vous prie madame combien de
trois garçons trois garçons des gars à
vous poser une question qui n'est pas
tout à fait deux leur sort uniquement
des femmes avec une recentrer uniquement
des problèmes féminins
est ce que vous avez est-ce que l'une
d'entre vous a une idole en matière de
cinéma de théâtre que ce soit en france
ou à l'étranger personne que le tracteur
possible personnage à la fois leur
devenir
j'ai pas d'idole jeu actuel à la
génération actuelle annie girardot p je
crois que s'ils unissent johnny star bon
mais johnny ça c'est un imprésario et
une idée c'est une coutume célébré
sérieux enfin ce fut l'imprésario johnny
hallyday du minibus et est-ce qu'il vous
viendrez à l'idée d'acheter et vrigne
peut-être vous avez tellement les volets
sont elles sont aggravées puis les
mélanges entre les scènes le plafond et
s'est dit dale chez moi qu'est-ce qu'il
vous viendrez à l'idée mesdames de
d'acheter des vêtements ils ont été
portés ou ayant appartenu à l'une de vos
idoles soit monsieur johnny star soit
madame non donc ça vous intéresse pas
même si on voulait proposer pour des
sommes minimes aux moments importants
par leur préférence à donner je ne
dépense vous savez que les femmes
américaines où les américains en général
n'ont pas tout à fait les mêmes
réactions vous puisque j'ai là une
coupure de journal qui indique qu'on a
vendu pour 200 francs nouveau un bicorne
pour 3300 francs une jupe en coton pour
3500 francs à voile de mariée et pour
6875 france admirer la précision à
l'imperméable il faut dire que ses
vêtements appartenaient à des acteurs
extrêmement connue comme charles
laughton judy garland d'elizabeth taylor
et clark gable et c'était une vente aux
enchères
y a pas de petits profits qui organisait
la métro goldwin meyer pour céder les
costumes qu'elle n'avait plus d'emploi
ça se passait au lit voilà nous allons
passer à un autre sujet dans un instant
[Musique]
sur les s'élever
dans le ciel bleu de bâtera s'ennuie
heures
encore la main
nous n'étions plaisantin
je
win partout
voyage
sans dire un mot dans l'herbe ou
ressemblons à marcher et j'ai pensé
quelle belle journée
oh
là
auray nous enveloppait nous étions seuls
sur un nouveau rival
oh
caressez puisqu'il est très bas sur ton
passage
pour jouer dans tes cheveux
avec le soleil vous sûr tempère singes
[Musique]
quelle belle journée on a goûté le petit
tampon aussi dans la sphère
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jambon
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était si douce de poule et devient tôt
[Musique]
tenant par la main pendant des enfants
sages
les petits dans la brière
mon père
[Musique]
e
les yeux
je t'ai regardé et j'ai passé
cas de bonne journée
le la
il a fallu rentrer
stella forest fini le beau voyage eux
s'arrêter
mais tu apprécies guerre
vion de froid jeu
et la prochaine fois je te promets du
restaurant
mais quelle belle
journet nous
mais la pro
restaurant
m
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien qu'on se rende pas avec ce que
je fais en ce moment j'ai raconté celle
des fleurs que jour distribué tout à
l'heure disons qu'en ce moment je suis à
l'olympia mais pour très peu de temps
jusqu'au 31 mai renvoyé et oui qu'est ce
que vous allez faire exceller et bien
voilà je vous savez l'olympia c'est
bientôt la fin mais alors c'est
l'inauguration de votre émission et je
vous propose lui une chose je vous
propose en a proposé de faire le
distributeur de fleurs et alors je
trouve que ce rôle là je pense que je
m'en sortirais pas trop mal vous
permettez campagne la concurrence je
vais poser le micro jusque là et je m'en
vais donner d'abord d un bouquet à
madame françoise rosay et ensuite à
toutes ces dames voulez bien alors pour
inaugurer cette émission je suis les
matches ne voulait pas selon lui sauf
qu'on lui donne on les vend pas voilà et
à la mariée bien sûr un bouquet blanchet
pas fait exprès par monsieur ministre
excusez moi non mais comment sa mère
marcelle passé non je fais comme ça là
voilà et meilleurs voeux de bonheur mais
madame
[Musique]
puisque c'est le ministre du tourisme et
je crois que après ce week-end
ensoleillé que nous voulons vivre
heureusement pour les fêtes de pentecôte
bien la france entière si ce n'est déjà
fait à penser ou plutôt à repenser non
nous allons l'intention de traiter un
certain nombre de ces problèmes
inhérents aux vacances nous parlons de
problèmes de l'hôtel des locations du
camping du caravaning mais avec vous
monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui si vous
voulez nous allons faire la préface nous
allons écrire la préface de ses vacances
1970 ce que nous espérons évidemment le
plus ensoleillé possible en tout cas au
moins aussi ensoleillée que ce que nous
avons connu pour les fêtes de ponderach
première question je voudrais vous poser
combien de temps combien de français
pratiquent des lacs
c'est ce que tout le monde prend des
vacances par roulement non et s'ils
n'ont commis y at-il de français qui
prennent réellement des vacances donc je
voudrais vous remercier d'avoir préfacé
votre émission aujourd'hui madame en
évoquant le problème des vacances et des
vacances pour les français je crois que
aujourd'hui le jour est particulièrement
choisi car ces légumes des toutes
premières journées ensoleillées
c'est là a eu une heureuse préfacé
quelque chose d'éminemment sympathie à
peine sont finies les vacances d'hiver
que l'on pense aux vacances d'été et il
est bien évident ce que là cela
préoccupe beaucoup de françaises
mais beaucoup de français et s'ils sont
aussi nombreux que l'an dernier je pense
qu'ils le seront davantage et et bien ce
sont en définitive plus de 24 millions
de françaises et de français qui vont
prendre leurs vacances car il en fut
ainsi en 1969 24 millions de français
sont allés en vacances 4 millions sont
allés à l'étranger 20 millions sont
demeurés en france ce qui est curieux
c'est de réaliser comment ces gens là
organisent leurs vacances et bien sûr
ses 20 millions de français qui sont
demeurés en france si l'on excepte les
deux millions qui ont pris leurs
vacances d'hiver
s'agissant et d'autres vacances 37% sont
allés chez des parents ou chez des amis
de 18% entre des raisons budgétaires se
pose depuis de raisons affectives aussi
serré son jeu
rafik est budgétée pour notre commune et
enfin il il en est ainsi et 18 % ont
choisi de les meublés des locations en
meublé 10% seulement vont en hôtellerie
traditionnelle et le reste c'est à dire
12 % vont te en notant ping et 10 % font
appel à ces installations qui sont
prévues pour ce l'on appelle le tourisme
social ou le tourisme un fils fils
familiales voilà de quelle façon serait
à kehl à quelle époque les français
pratiquent en vacances en algarve
juillet en août en septembre
non alors il ya ces deux millions de
français qui prennent leurs vacances
l'hiver tout seul c'est parfait pour les
autres ceux qui prennent leurs vacances
l'été il est évidemment quelque peu
regrettable d'imaginer que 80% de ceux
ci prennent leurs vacances entre le 15
juillet et le 25 août
c'est regrettable pour quoi et c'est le
but de cette émission c'est de faire en
sorte que les françaises et des français
puis je prendre leurs vacances dans les
meilleures conditions tant sur le plan
pécuniaire que sur le plan de la qualité
de l'accueil de la prestation il est
bien certain que si tout le monde a ri
dans le même moment et pour bénéficier
des mêmes choses sa prose quelques
modèles que ça nous aussi s'il n'était
donnée ce jour d'indiquer à chacun comme
l'a traduit d'ailleurs une récente
enquête de l'ifop
combien le mois de juin est agréable
puisque 23 pour salles ont choisi un
bien le mois de juillet est séduisant
puisque 30% l'ont retenu le mois d'août
montrent pas d'agrément 10 intéressant
les loisirs mais le mois de septembre
quel agrément et quelle chance surtout
cette année avec bill evans y seraient
opposés 15 septembre de vous livrer aux
questions des téléspectatrices qui sont
là et qui sont elles aussi concernées
par le problème des vacances
ni stress à vous que nous mère de
famille devant un prolongement de huit
jours de vacances pour nos lycées qui
arrive en un petit peu comme ça en
dernière minute n'est pas toujours
facile à régler
vous allez dans la vie rien se fait seul
et en définitive c'est la somme des
efforts et des préoccupations de chacun
dans notre souci d'une part eux
d'apporter aux enfants le maximum de
temps de détente et de l'organiser sur
le plan des mois deux dans le cadre des
mois d'été de façon telle que on puisse
éviter les inconvénients que tout alors
j'ai indiqué c'est l'une des raisons
pour lequel pour lesquels le lycée demi
d'éducation nationale et le premier
ministre qui a arbitré en cette affaire
ont convenu de l'opportunité de reporter
cette entrée 2 2 qui était prévu
initialement au 3 septembre au 14 70
serre qui lui était ce que table de
faire connaître cette décision plus tôt
mais je fais confiance tout de même aux
préoccupations des français au sang ceux
qui l'ont d'organisation jus persuadé
que vous saurez et je le souhaite
on fit et utilement de ses onze journées
supplémentaires
d'autant plus qu'il fera très beau tout
ça vous en êtes sans le dire en tout cas
madame berthod aux enfants je suis sûr
sont les parents qui travaillent
c'est un gros problème c'était de
montrer en difficulté c'est de concilier
le temps de vacances et des enfants et
des parents
car il ya quelque chose de
particulièrement séduisant notre pays
c'est que parents et enfants pendant
vacances en même temps je n'ai pas
toujours facile le l'industrie à ces
exigences et qui ne peux pas te
permettre pas que je de mettre les dates
en harmonie enfin j'espère que tout de
même vous arrivez à vous organiser dans
le cadre de ces nouvelles dates
mademoiselle d'hui à une question à vous
poser monsieur ministre
les grands villages de vacances en fin
de je ne citerai pas le nom firme très
connu font-ils du tort au tourisme en
france mais pas du tout je peux changer
d'air que ce tourisme familial ce
tourisme social qui est parfaitement
illustré en ses possibilités d'accueil
par les villages vacances au par
l'egypte familiaux sont au contraire
répondent au contraire à des besoins
extrêmement important et d'un autre
souci en faveur des vacances et c'est là
l'un des secteurs où nous allons faire
de grands efforts pourquoi parce qu'ils
permettent d'obtenir pour des familles
pour des ménages des vacances à des prix
peut être plus avantageux que dans
l'hôtellerie traditionnelle parce que
l'organisation est un peu différent et
puis aussi parce qu'ils sont organisées
de façon telle que il libère la maman de
certaines obligations notamment au
regard des enfants petit ou grand
nous avons fait de grands efforts nous
avons actuellement soixante mille lits
et nous espérons augmenter les
possibilités en ce domaine de cinq ou
six mille lits par an et se trouve ça
extrêmement nécessaire autant que ça
patine en tout cas monsieur mini-jeux
retient entre autres choses de ce que
vous avez dit qu'il fera beau en 1970
nous tenons pour responsables si vous le
voulez bien nous vous retrouverons après
les vacances pour savoir si votre
prédiction a été vérifiée ou des jeunes
est une chance sur deux de me tromper
paiement et d'autre part c'était un
petit peu le lancement d'une enquête sur
les vacances que nous allons faire ici
dans cette émission et qui aura à
traiter des problèmes des locations des
problèmes d des enfants en vacances des
problèmes des camping-cars à ben ali et
ses accès je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion on peut parler ses problèmes
de la cance pour l'instant si vous le
permettez nous allons passer un tout
autre sujet
[Musique]
bon vous au cinéma comme à la télévision
avant que commencent les prises de vue
il y a le metteur en scène qui dit
moteur ensuite on présente devant le nez
de la peur c'est d'instruments qui
s'appelle abbas à paris 3e ça donne le
départ des prises de vue tout ceci pour
vous expliquer qu'une histoire de cinéma
qui est arrivé à pierre brasseur quand
ils devraient dans un film de carné il
tourne est un film je crois que c'est
quai des brumes je n'ai pas je suis
persuadé d'ailleurs et la scène était la
suivante brasseur a fraudé chercher sa
petite amie qui s'était enfui il sortait
du taxi et il appelait sa petite amie
s'était elle s'appelait de mal où il
avait à sortir un flic taxi en criant
baluba non madame blue est ce ce prénom
de malouda faisait tout un drame dans le
studio car carnet qui est un monsieur
très intransigeant sujet de forte colère
merveilleux d'ailleurs avec raison et il
n'arrivait pas à trouver de l'intonation
de cette malu malu alors leurs bras
surface et malouda et non non tu
comprends pierre fait par malu malu êtes
bien de la malu malu malu et pendant une
heure on répétait le malu malu malu malu
malu tourmenté surexcités entre deux
coupures bras sur ses talons bravo écart
des cétacés le ton va tout de suite on y
va tout de suite on présente le clap on
top
le metteur en scène fait fuir pas
surfaite moteur dans cette émission
aujourd'hui cinéma
le théâtre est à peine besoin de vous la
présentez vous aident à voir apparaître
sur votre écran madame françoise rosay
puisqu'il s'agit de vous on essaie nous
allons préparer une petite fille cheveux
aussi elle est si vous permettez je
viens donner connaissance à tous ceux
qui nous prêtent attention aujourd'hui
il faut d'abord mais ça vaut mieux ré
autoriser tout à l'heure que j'indique
votre âge avec des joies vous avez en
effet 79 ans oui vous êtes né le 19
avril ce qui va évidemment sans dire
1880 vous vous êtes mariés en juillet
1917 avec celui qui devait devenir le
célèbre metteur en scène jacques feyder
vous avez trois enfants deux
petits-enfants et vous avez tourné sans
six films
la kermesse héroïque drôle de drame le
grand jeu pour ne citer que ces trois là
et très récemment et très récemment un
film avec michel audiard il ne faut pas
prendre les enfants du bon dieu pour des
canards sauvages
vous parlez l'anglais et l'allemand d
vous avez eu autrefois des activités
journalistiques comme de dans des
périodiques féminin et puis aussi
pendant la guerre on vous a entendu à la
radio de l'or et un sens pas du tout ça
c'est ça y est c'est fini
dans le jeu je me permets simplement un
autre nous simplement que j'ai trois
fils et deux petits fils je suivais aux
garçons dans cette année trois fils est
actuellement et bien vous jouez à la
comédie des champs-elysées jouer une
pièce qui s'appelle cher antoine une
pièce d'anouilh qui a dépassé la deux
centième représentation degré innocents
sans grades des 125 puisque nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
que la couturière la générale j'ai passé
plutôt que derrière madame si vous le
permettez du jeu parce qu'un petit peu
votre modestie je dois dire que ma fiche
indique encore je la lis d'ailleurs son
commentaire générosité de coeur inspire
affection admiration et respect n'aime
pas parler d'elle personnellement et
pour quand madame c'est ce que je vais
vous demander de faire aujourd'hui de le
faire m ennuie pour nous avec nos
téléspectatrices non seulement celles
qui sont présentes ici sur le plateau
mais aussi avec celle qui nous prêtent
attention chez elle quant à leurs fruits
ce que nous voudrions essayer de définir
avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
ce sont des choses importantes de la vie
qu'elles sont plus françoise rosay les
choses importantes de la vie il est bien
entendu que pour chaque individu pour
chaque personne les choses peuvent
différer mais je voudrais connaître les
vôtres est-ce qu'on peut les choses il
ya une chose essentielle pour tous les
côtés les riches les pauvres les grands
les plus les races les jaunes les vernis
noir c'est d'abord une bonne santé je
vous écris par unis ça c'est pas bien
c'est vous qui seriez pas non mais après
alors les choses essentielles de la vie
mais je vous écoute par dieu on ne peut
pas le dire puisque ça dépend un peu
naître très très riche on peut mettre
trappe or en peu de lettres
mon dieu bourgeois moyens bourgeois ils
ont pas pu mettre notre façon mais je
crois que pour les riches et pour les
pauvres ne pas nous existons la misère
parce que l'homme trémolat sommes
vraiment misérable il ya la chose avant
tout c est hélas de manger trois fois
par jour si possible et de dormir dans
un lit d'avoir chaud et de plus à rabieh
ses enfants dans sa exploit se loger
mais ça c'est autre chose en dehors qui
est une chose cruelle de la vie métier
comme ça qu'il n'aura pas à la nature
c'est ça il faut manger faut dormir
parce que quand tu te feras d'or mais
ceci dit ce que je conseillerai pas une
consigne pas mais j'ai l'impression que
chacun riche ou pauvre peut être heureux
en regardant et en appréciant ce qu'il a
parce que avant tout j'ai remarqué que
les gens très riches les gens qui ont dû
roduit riche et la trois voitures en
gueule et baky ce sont des gens qui se
plaignent tout le temps où là les
valeurs baissent le yacht a fait
9 le palais domestiques sont
insupportables à bagua ils sont toujours
triste va presque toujours triste et ils
s'ennuient sens ni parce qu'ils ont
tellement de choses qui n'ont pu leur
être maria regarde et je crois que dans
la vie il faut apprécier ce qu'on a et
ça vous donne un optimisme il faut aimer
ce qu'on nations les canaris faut le
regarder pousser il faut tous les
missionnaires un tout petit jardin il
faut regarder pousser les fleurs et les
aimer et surtout si on travaille il faut
aimer son métier est alors le travail
devient une récompense dont il lui faut
savoir se contenter de ce qu'on a obtenu
ne pas être au moment précis je ne
souviens très bien quand j'étais jeune
et quand j'ai débuté j'allais à pied à
l'odéon l'omnibus coûtait cissouma maire
mme lena les 6 ou mais j'aimais mieux
regarder j'allais à pied de montmartre
de l'argent talent et gens venaient à
pied sa douce ou alors je traversais le
cade je m'achetais un croissant exquis
d'une tablette de chocolat pouvait faire
des papouilles alors je traversais le
carrousel par exemple mais je vous
assure que le calme plat de course c'est
merveilleux fleurs j'avais l'impression
d'être uyar d'air j'avais un palais gt
gt gt risque étant riche en main j'étais
riche j'étais heureuse et je crois que
c'est ça il ne faut pas à garder le
voile ingrat qui le plus pur et cheveux
en tant que riches et les plus heureux
c'est pas vrai et l'amour
oh mon cher ami si longtemps mais enfin
ça fait partie de la nature c'est une
chose essentielle qui n'existent pas
toujours on tombe même quelquefois en
face à je laisse à vos jeunes femmes qui
sont là de soin de découvrir les bons
éléments chromés un conseil de jeunes
mariés ça dépend desquels si on les
connaît ce jeu si on ne connaît pas je
crois qu'on se marier et mon dieu
l'amour avec une femme belles choses
même
aussi la mort devient fatalement autre
chose je crois que dans dans le mariage
il faut épouser une personne tient enfin
au moins si vous voulez pas l'idéal mais
la même conception de la vie en
angleterre et dizzy feet qui font peser
le monsieur qui mangent comme vous qui
se tient table comme vous je crois que
c'est assez juste une femme profitera
bien élevé peut être très éprise d'un
homme très vulgaire est mal élevé au
bout de temps d'en souffrir
je crois que ça et puis ya travaillé
dans le même sens tirer la charrue
ensemble sur youtube
c'est un travail d'équipé d'une petite
équipe mais très importante et qui vous
parle et a aussi avoir une certaine base
d'idées semblables savoir que lui ne est
incapable de faire ceci sur les climats
et bling vous écoute avec une attention
oui vous voyez beaucoup de jeunes
comédiens autour de vous est ce que vous
allez trouver différentes des réactions
vous pouviez avoir quand vous aviez 20
ans les jeunes comédiennes non elles ne
sont pas différentes elles font les
mêmes âneries
elles sont en culotte nous étions en
jupe enfin sol elles sont les mêmes
jeunes qui tourne à travers les âges on
peut aller dans la lune ou affronter
n'importe quoi elles sont jeunes fuient
elles ont les mêmes ennuis
elles ont plus d'audace que nous
n'avions ce que je me reproche aux
jeunes si l'on peut dire n'est ce pas
parce que je les aime bien et je les
plains pour ça ce sont des jeunes qui
m'ont pas d'humilité et qu'ils n'ont pas
keane admire les élèves en général du
pack tous naturellement mais les petites
froid encore et cela dure journaux par
deux manches a remis des des journaux
qui parlent de jeunes filles qui vont
rencontrer un metteur en scène qui vont
vous êtes super vous êtes la femme qu'il
me faut vladia au foehn et je vous en
êtes maladroit ça il faut très
décolletée tounsi possible assez parfait
malheureusement notre métier implique da
pont des textes et les jouets alors dans
qu'elle recommence elles ont les mêmes
en est que nous avons eu nous avons
appris notre métier mais ce qu'elles ont
surtout à ne pas battre me rase et le
montage a fixé son indic nous étions les
tanguy et nous souvient nous étions
pleins d'admiration pour le grand grand
grand acteur nous et je crois que dans
la vie admirer s'enthousiasmer c'est
merveilleux peut-être sont-elles
préoccupé madame berthod à une question
à vous poser
pouvez vous nous avez signé c'est très
juste que l'importance il est très
important d'avoir un travail pour lequel
on se passionnaient est malin il ya de
plus en plus forcément de femmes qui
travaillent c'est normal est ce que par
exemple dans votre cas est ce que vous
avez eu de problème douloureux au point
de vue lorsque les enfants sont jeunes
et ont besoin
mr ont besoin d'en passer par là
j'estime jusqu'à 7 8 ans il faut que la
mer soit tout de même plus de plus
possible près des enfants jeunes et
c'est quand même un problème difficile
une femme qui est un métier passionnant
qui est très prise par son métier
lacharme à la plage vous arrête n'y a
rien de plus passionnant que la
maternité l'importance de l'enfant c'est
la même chose dans toutes les classes de
la société à passion mais vraiment une
mère mais il est évident qu'il est très
difficile pour une femme qui travaille
qui a un travail régulier dans le nord
qui n'est pas régulier soit vous faites
un film parfait pendant un mois trois
mois et à vous pouvez rester neuf mois
sans rien fait un espace guardian et le
notre travail n'est pas régulier le vote
en face aux scènes clés mais lyon d'un
travail régulier doivent évidemment
s'organiser vote évidemment s'organiser
alors quelques fois la grand-mère
entrevues et peut remplacer la maman
qu'elle a élevées en somme dans le
calcul et il est évident c'était pas
dévisser quand la jeune maman n'a pas de
parents autour d'elle alors il faut
qu'elle trouve quelqu'un qui ne saurait
quelques enfants qu'elle est tout à fait
confiance confiance et puissent confier
l'enfant est là c'est la difficulté
contre heureuse et je me permets de vous
interrompre
je me permets de l'intérieur car il ya
des tas de gens chaque personne qui se
trouve en haut
qu'est ce que nous voyons pas qu'ils
vont faire les gros yeux si nous dessert
majorelle marasme général ça devrait
vous proposer de revenir demain à à
quelle heure
les meilleurs 14h30 donc nous parlera en
dotant parle d'autre chose et là
françoise rosay vient de vous indiquer
qu'elle était pour elle les choses
importantes de la vie mais je pense que
comme je disais tout à l'heure pour
certains d'entre vous certains d'entre
vous les choses importantes de la vie ne
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes que
celles françoise rosay alors vous pouvez
nous écrire sur une petite carte postale
sûr d'être en face que vous voulez pour
nous indiquer aussi quels sont pour vous
les choses importantes de la vie en
déclassant si vous voulez la moule à la
santé en fabrique et 7 ans parmi ces
lettres que nous choisirons celles
d'entre vous qui participeront à cette
émission comme nous trois invités
aujourd'hui ils auraient passé
maintenant à notre sujet jérôme nous
allons nous dire au revoir
nous retrouvons demain à 14 heures bien
qu'ils t'ont pas puisque le feuilleton
va arriver il s'agit de ma sorcière bien
aimée c'est ça c'est le feuilleton
il est formidable espions c'est
passionnant mais je voudrais d'abord
remercier monsieur et madame gilbert 6b
c'est une dépêche qu'on m'apporte à
l'instant qu'habite bréhat la ville en
meurthe et moselle
ils ont 19 ans de mariage aujourd'hui 19
nerfs alors beaucoup de bonheur pour eux
encore beaucoup d'années de maria
absolue encore beaucoup de rendez vous
pour nous donc voici ma sorcière bien
aimée
[Musique]